Israel is heading for the polls again
when my they it's the fifth general
election in just four years and the
ballot looks fairly familiar too former
prime minister Benjamin Netanyahu is
looking to replace current Premier dryer
lapete the Challenger leads in the polls
but might have to rely on the far right
to propel him to Victory
the seasons may change but the question
for Israeli voters Remains the Same
divisive former prime minister Benjamin
Bibi Netanyahu is vying for a return to
power campaigning across the country in
his now Infamous bulletproof BB bus
this time no one stays home everyone
should go and vote liquid
[Applause]
his main opponent
Israel's current caretaker prime
minister and head of the Centrist yes
party lapi took over as prime minister
after his Eight party coalition
government collapsed in June
in this election
there's one thing we need to know about
that it's close
you watch TV like I do
but we know how to turn around a tight
election
tight elections are Deja Vu for Israelis
who have voted four times in as many
years
will win they will have 34 seats and the
rice will win big time
it's a boring campaign no one will
deliver what we need
but now with all his trials
I don't want him to run the country
to form a coalition government
candidates need 61 out of 120 knesset
seats final polls predict Netanyahu and
his aligned right-wing religious parties
at 60 seats just one seat short of a
majority La petite's block is lagging
slightly behind but nothing is certain
yet
think that these elections are about
liberalism versus nationalism the Big
Ideas
personified in two people liberalism in
lapid and his kind of Camp nationalism
personified in Netanyahu and his very
clear Camp it's also about this man
itama penguir from the far right
Alliance religious Zionism they're
currently polling third if they do that
well it could make this one's Fringe
figure the king maker for netanyahu-led
Coalition Netanyahu actually embracing
him and with Netanyahu the entire liquid
MKS keep on saying what's the problem
with itamar benver you know why
shouldn't we Embrace him so I mean it's
like uh writing the uh the tiger and the
back of the tiger and how the tiger is
now more powerful than the the rest of
them
Netanyahu who is facing corruption
charges in court has just published his
Memoir soon he will know whether he will
be the one to write the next chapter in
Israeli politics
and our correspondent Tanya Kramer filed
that report and has of course much more
to tell us Tanya Israelis face a
familiar choice and Netanyahu is again
at the center of it all how heavy do the
corruption charges weigh over him and
his campaign
[Applause]
well I think you just said it I mean for
many Israelis here it feels like it's
another kind of referendum on the former
long-term prime minister Benjamin
Netanyahu is now the opposition leader
and he wants to return to power again
now he can do so I mean nothing in
Israel Israeli legislation prevents him
from running again as the head of the
likud although he is facing corruption
charges he has to fight for his
innocence in court now we should not
forget uh he has still a very large
Faith he could his party is usually the
largest party it also is predicted in
the polls up to the election now as
again the largest party and you know I
talked to some of his supporters also
now on the campaign Trail they always
say rock Bibi that means only baby and
only he can actually provide the safety
the security
for it's for Israel's citizens that's
their take but of course the it runs
against pull in in it runs along
political lines here you have those who
are supporting him and who want him to
return to power and those who say no
because just he is sitting in court
basically uh he cannot run the country
again and those who are really horrified
for him uh to return now if you're
looking at the last polls the final
polls that were published uh on Friday
by the three uh main television channels
here we've been seeing that it's a very
very tight race uh the likud and Mr
Netanyahu with his liquid and the his
religious writing blog they would reach
60 seats you need 61 seats out of 120
seats in the knesset
so this is a very very tight race as we
see but on the other hand it could also
be just a once more an inconclusive
election and we could see another
election and sometime soon let's talk
about the potential King makers here how
do people feel about likud's alliance
with the far-right religious Zionism
party
but I think that has been you know here
in the headlines for the whole election
campaign the rise of the far right we're
talking here about the alliance
religious Zionism this is an alliance of
three parties and one of the leaders
number two actually on the list that we
saw it in the report itama bengui has
become a bit the poster boy in this
election campaign he's all over the
place you could say he's on TV channels
he's giving a lot of interviews and uh
it is it is a very
um you know strange way to see how the
far right and the extremist views
especially from itama bengvir who used
to be known as a supporter of the late
um
who was an extremist a leader he was
assassinated in 1990 he was the head of
the car party that was a party that was
outlawed as a Tarot organization in the
US and in Israel and Mr item we are also
has been indicted several times for
incitement so it is a very strange
campaign to see him coming up so high in
the polls which this Alliance could be
the third largest party and as we heard
in the report they could be potentially
the king makers in Netanyahu led a
coalition if he can build a coalition
and they could become becoming you know
rather influential in some of the
Ministries one key demographic though to
stop and that Yahoo Victory could be
Arab Israelis but it seems like they're
somewhat reluctant to vote explain it to
us why that is
well I think we have to wait and see
there has been a lot of focus on uh the
uh turnout the voter turnout in the Arab
Community a minority about 20 percent of
Israel's population but I think it's
still too early to tell because there
have been you know the polls are given
not a clear picture at the moment there
have been like polls are going lower
than 40 turn out and up to 50 that's the
latest polls I've been seeing and the
water turnout that is important for the
party blocks because a lower voter
turnout in the Arab Community could mean
that it would benefit Mr Netanyahu and
his right-wing religious blog a higher
turnout goodness benefit Mr lapid the
current prime minister of the caretaker
government and if you talk to people
from the community you know they have
reasons not going to vote but there are
also those who will go towards so I
think you know we still have to wait to
see what the voter turnout is but some
would say you know that um we we don't
feel that we are really seen you know
what impact do we have especially if you
see right now there has been an Arab
party in the government and the last
government the Eight party Coalition uh
government and still you know we're
seeing at the same time now the the rise
of the far right Tanya Kramer in
Jerusalem thank you so much
[Applause]